'josé luis' gavidia renunció al cargo de
ministro de defensa que venía
desempeñando desde febrero de este año
en su carta de dimisión le ha firme al
presidente pedro castillo que su
renuncia se debe razones estrictamente
personales en breve diálogo con algunos
periodistas david afirmó que su salida
del gobierno no se debe a la actual
crisis política ni a los
cuestionamientos a su gestión por
supuestas irregularidades la fiscalía lo
investiga por el presunto delito de
peculado por usar un vuelo oficial para
trasladarse con sus hijas a una
provincia además una denuncia
periodística el acusa de supuestamente
realizar gastos excesivos usando la caja
chica del sector defensa por otro lado
la contraloría investiga un contrato del
ministerio de la producción a su esposa
ha firmado tres días después de que gabi
de a jurar al cargo de ministro de
defensa la orden de servicio por un
plazo de 75 días autoriza el pago de más
de 6 mil dólares según un semanario el
organismo investiga si la esposa de
gavidia incurrió en un caso de conflicto
de intereses y nepotismo jose gaviria
ha descartado que su salida esté
relacionado con este tema mientras tanto
el presidente de pedro castillo se
dedica a buscar a un nuevo ministro de
defensa